Dove l'ho messa 'sta roba..?
Oh eccola qua.
Oh, porca puttana..!
[Suono sordo dell'interruttore della luce]
Non funziona più?
No, dai eh..! Per favore...
Oh, okay!
[Respiro affannoso]
Salve...
Posso immaginare quali siano i vostri dubbi, al momento; del tipo: "Ma dove sei..? Cosa cazzo stai facendo della tua vita..?", e sopratutto "Perché non ci sono video..?".
Be', per rispondere alla vostra domanda... sono chiuso in un bagno, in questo momento.
[Rumore dello scarico d'acqua del water]
Perché il modo che si trova là fuori fa paura, e per questo non voglio andarci.
Guarda un po': ora mi comporto proprio come i bambini che si chiudono nell'armadio, quando provano paura; non me ne frega niente..!
Perché dovrei uscire, e farmi assalire dallo stress, dalle paure e dalle incertezze..?
Potrei semplicemente rimanere qui dentro per sempre, e avere ugualmente a disposizione tutto ciò di cui ho bisogno per vivere.
C'è un sacco di acqua potabile,
c'è una ventola che mi permette di respirare;
perché dovrei soffrire..?
[Sospiro]
Non ce la posso fare.
Su Youtube, in questo momento, si sta vivendo un periodo di paura:
perché tutta 'sta pagliacciata che abbiamo tirato su nell'arco di questi 10 anni...
sta crollando, proprio come un castello di carte.
E tutto questo sta portando alla luce nell'animo delle persone la loro vera natura;
perché la gente lo sa benissimo, che gli "Youtuber" non sono esattamente come li si vede in video:
quella è soltanto una "Pirandellata", soltanto una maschera.
E il nostro essere "noi stessi"... è questo:
un branco di caga sotto, di conigli, che non hanno neanche la faccia tosta di affrontare un problema..!
E siccome gli "Youtuber" sono [con tono di sfottò]
"persone vere", e bla, bla, bla... "anche loro provano dei sentimenti, come voi: non dovreste metterli su un piedistallo"...
siamo tutti, TUTTI così.
E io, da 'sto bagno, non voglio uscire..!
Quel topo lì, che giace in quell'angolo, è appena diventato il mio migliore amico; e non voglio lasciarlo da solo.
[Sospiro]
E allora, okay: vi mostro dove mi trovo.
...Ho preso in affitto un nuovo ufficio.
♪♫♪ [In sottofondo, il motivetto jazz che funge da sigla alla serie "Late Show con Karim Musa"] ♪♫♪
Benvenuti nell'ultima puntata della Prima Stagione del "Late Show con Karim Musa"..!
Vi chiedo scusa per l'audio;
ma, come potrete certamente capire, essendo ancora tutto completamente vuoto il suono rimbomba come fosse una chiesa sconsacrata.
Dunque, di cosa parleremo oggi...
Ah, giusto: ho paura di rimanere senza lavoro.
Ebbene sì, tutti su Youtube stanno correndo ai ripari:
chi si sta "cagando addosso",
chi sta più volte sbattendo la testa contro lo spigolo della sua scrivania,
chi apre una pagina di Patreon ma senza mostrare la cifra monetaria che gli viene donata dalla gente,
e chi invece prende in mano un pezzo di cartone con su scritto "Non ho più un soldo; ero uno Youtuber" e si dirige direttamente in strada.
E, quindi... [Con tono volutamente esagerato]
"Oh, mio Dio: cosa sta succedendo su Youtube?!?"
Lo sapete, cosa sta succedendo su Youtube.
Ne avrete sicuramente sentito parlare anche da Shy del canale "Breaking Italy"
(nel caso non abbiate avuto modo di guardare questo suo video, vi inserirò il link inerente nella sezione della "Descrizione del Video"),
ma ne hanno parlato anche quelli di "Quei Due Sul Server": in pratica, ne ha parlato chiunque..!
E quindi, per l'amor di Dio... panico in sala stampa..! Panico in sala stampa..!
E questa "Adpocalypse" avrete modo di notarla anche voi osservando i recenti movimenti virtuali dei vostri Youtuber preferiti, divisi in 5 semplici fasi:
1) "cagarsi addosso";
2) parlare dell'argomento "Adpocalypse";
3) "cagarsi addosso";
4) correre ai ripari, mettere mille mani avanti e cercare una soluzione;
5) chiedere direttamente dei soldi dalla gente da cui si è seguiti.
E io capisco le ragioni di ogni singolo comportamento manifestato da queste persone.
E sapete perché..? Perché noi Youtuber abbiamo una data di scadenza, tatuata nel retro del nostro culo.
Tutti affermano che Youtube sia [con tono da annunciatore pubblicitario] il "trampolino di lancio, per poi fare qualcosa di grandioso con la tua vita..!"
No, sapete che cosa è davvero Youtube..?
Youtube è il quarto d'ora di notorietà, moltiplicato per 10 anni.
E la cosa più sbagliata che tu possa fare quando godi di un po' di notorietà e di entrate monetarie abbastanza cospicue è dimenticarti di questa sua natura.
Ogni volta che su Youtube si viene a creare un problema, nella nostra testa non si forma un pensiero del tipo:
"Dai, cerchiamo di sistemarlo, rattoppando qui e inchiodando un asse di legno là per non far crollare il muro della nostra vita";
no, no, no, no. Quello che si viene a verificare ogni volta che si riscontra un piccolissimo problema è il sentire questa vocina nella nostra testa
(che è sempre dentro di noi, ma che si risveglia solamente quando su Yotuube si verifica un problema),
che ti sussurra: "Ohibò, prepara la vasellina e vatti a fare un bel bidet, perché te lo stanno per mettere nel culo..!
Non dimenticartelo mai, mi raccomando..!"
(Mortacci sua...)
E capisci che la soluzione del "Vai a lavorare negli alti forni, in miniera..!", che la gente ti propone in modo aggressivo,
potrebbe avere un piccolo fondo di verità.
Ma sussiste un problema:
noi non disponiamo di un vero e proprio curriculum; quello che portiamo su Youtube è... fuffa..!
A noi manco ci prendono a lavorare negli alti forni, perché non abbiamo esperienza.
Louis C.K. è solito dire nei suoi spettacoli che «uscire da un lungo matrimonio sia un po' come uscire di prigione»; ovvero, intende dire che devi ricominciare con la tua vita.
Ecco, con Youtube è la stessa cosa: tu devi uscire da un periodo in cui non hai fatto EFFETTIVAMENTE nulla;
e, quindi, ti devi preparare a trovare un lavoro congruo con quella che risulta essere la tua esperienza lavorativa.
Ma prima che arrivi il periodo in cui andrò a lavare i piatti in una pizzeria
(perché arriverà - tempo un paio di anni, e quel momento arriverà),
è mia intenzione lasciare qualcosa di me qui.
È fin dal momento in cui raggiunsi la soglia del milione di Iscritti, da quando mi arrivò a casa il "Mega-Gold Button" di Youtube
(per complimentarsi del raggiungimento del milione di Iscritti)
che io ho deciso che su questa piattaforma desidero lasciare qualcosa... lasciare un'impronta di me.
Ed è proprio per questa ragione che ho realizzato meno video, ma con argomentazioni più mirate;
mi spiego meglio: i video che io presento sul mio canale (che piacciano o meno, dato che ve ne sono di tante tipologie)
risultano essere comunque "memorabili", ovvero ci si ricorda di loro... di qual è il video che non si è gradito o che è piaciuto maggiormente, di cosa parlano quei video, di cosa è accaduto sul mio canale.
Non sono il frutto di una pubblicazione di tre video al giorno, dei quali a nessuno frega un cazzo.
E questo video, proprio come parlavo all'inizio, risulta essere il finale
(quello vero, perché io ho realizzato anche una specie di Finale di Metà Prima Stagione dello Show con quel video riguardante il vecchio ufficio):
questo è proprio il finale concreto della Prima Stagione.
E la Seconda Stagione inizierà... DA QUI..!
L'ho detto come fosse il finale di una puntata di "È Domenica, Papà!"...
[Con tono giocoso] "Da qui, bimbi..!"
Come avete avuto modo di vedere, ho deciso di realizzare questo video da qui, per mostrarvi che vi è ancora dell'altro lavoro da portare avanti.
E questo è quello che tenevo a dirvi. Non tanto a voi, tra l'altro: pubblico che sa meglio di noi "Youtuber" che non dureremo ancora per dell'altro tempo;
ma l'ho realizzato sopratutto per ricordarlo a me stesso, e per ribadire anche ai miei "colleghi" del Web ("Youtuber" o "Content Creator"che siano)
che fra qualche anno dovremmo organizzare una piccola "riunione di condominio" per decidere le sorte della nostra vita...
♪♫♪ [In sottofondo, parte della sigla finale della serie "Late Show con Karim Musa"] ♪♫♪